comme celle-ci la Loire en possède des
centaines près de 600 km en tout des
ouvrages destinés à contenir les humeurs
du fleuve mais qui pour la plupart sont
vieux de plus de 400 ans lors de sa
visite dans le Val de Loire le député
Christian Kert a constaté pas moins de
163 brèches on a noté que il y a des
points de sensibilité des points de
fragilité sur les digues que elles sont
que ces points sont quasiment imp car
comme toute œuvre humaine bon il y a des
il y a des difficultés tout n'est pas
homogène tout n'est pas homogène mais la
grande majorité des digues de Loire ont
notamment subi les affres de la grande
crue de 1856 dont le pont Wilson porte
encore les marques aujourd'hui en Touren
ce sont 150000 personnes qui se
retrouveraient les pieds dans l'eau si
une telle crue se reproduisait aucun
risque en revanche pour une petite
inondation type décembre 2003 car depuis
les années 60 les efforts d'entretien se
sont multi
les digs de Loire sont sont heureusement
bien
entretenus depuis depuis des décennies
elles sont bien entretenu elles sont
restauré sont renforcé dans le cadre du
Plan Loire grandeur nature avec
la l'aide des collectivités local des
départements des régions de certaines
communes donc on est plutôt plutôt en
avance mais les grandes auteurs des
Diges de Loire et la population qu'elle
protège 300000 habitants euh sont des
des facteurs à prendre en compte attendu
pour le début du mois de juin le rapport
du député Christian Kert dressera un
bilan précis de la situation en
val-deloire de nombreuses pistes visant
à la sécurisation de la Loire devrait
également être proposé